speaking of another hip-hop mogul jay-z
his music service title set out to save
the industry from the economics of
streaming but hasn't really turned the
tide The Wall Street Journal is
reporting that its interim CEO Peter Tom
sad has just been let go this is less
than three months into the job since
it's a highly publicized relaunch in
March ted olds backlash was immediate
with critics calling the service as
little more than a vehicle for jay-z to
make a fortune
so is this going to break hip-hop mogul
jay-z's almost unbroken record of
success mark Crumpton is here with me
now you know broken record of success
that seems it's been going on throughout
his entire career you mentioned that mr.
Tom Stipe was only on the job for three
months that was in an interim basis but
look at what title is up against less
than a million subscribers no free tier
Spotify has about 20 million paying
customers this is probably not the time
when you want to merry-go-round going on
in the executive suite of this company
yeah they've got a huge amount of
competition from a lot of the most
powerful companies in the world honestly
including Apple rolling out new
streaming music products and a lot of
people say that maybe he just sort of
bungled the PR launch because he had the
most successful most well-off artists up
there on stage with him everybody from
there you see Kanye West and his variety
is up there with his wife Beyonce
Madonna was up there and they're up
there campaigning for artists to make
more money it would it seemed from the
very beginning when you see that wide
shot and then when you see correctly as
you point out there's Alicia Keys some
of these very wealthy well-known artists
up there and the criticism was that it
seems like they had their hand back in
the till that they wanted exactly more
money and it didn't seem that there was
anybody looking out for the little guy
they got they got criticized pretty
round about that and then they're gonna
feel this competition also coming from
Apple as you mentioned getting ready to
launch the new streaming music service
and Taylor Swift making them change
their tune that's right
if t swift calls you out you're called
out yeah